Hello everybody and thank you for joining
us whether you're here on the campus of the
George Washington university or watching around
the country or actually around the world.
We're thrilled you could join us for this
citizen event. This is the fourth in a series
of in person citizen events that CNN is partnering
with the George Washington University on doing
right here on the George Washington campus.
It is part of a partnership that C. N. N.
And G. W. Have which also includes the brand
new ted turner professorship here at the School
of Media and Public Affairs which will be
introduced later this fall. So we're thrilled
to work with G. W. And we're thrilled that
all of you have joined us tonight to those
watching around the country. Um Please look
out for other citizen events particularly
as we move towards the midterm election visit
CNN dot com slash Citizen for information
on future events and we'll have quite a number
of them as the as election day draws near.
So speaking of Election Day, we are only six
weeks away from a really critical midterm
election. I think it's I think we can all
agree that this election and this election
season is turning out to be an awful a lot
more interesting than any of us had ever expected,
which means that you're in for a real treat
tonight. Uh Tonight. We will not only talk
about what to expect in the election but we
really want to focus on what's driving the
voters. Let's get behind the numbers and figure
out what it is that's moving moving the electorate.
Um Will it be inflation as republicans hope
or will it be abortion, for example, as democrats
hope these are the questions that we, the
CNN political team talk about amongst ourselves
all day long, but today you're gonna get an
opportunity to peer in on the on the conversation
with a terrific group from our team right
here on this stage. So without further ado,
I want to introduce your moderator for the
evening. Please welcome to the stage. CNN's
anchor and chief chief national affairs analyst
and perhaps for this crowd. Most important,
proud alumna of the George Washington University.
Please welcome Casey Hunt Sam. Um and thanks
to all of you for spending your Wednesday
evening with us. I'm actually really thrilled
to be back here. I also attended many political
events here in the Jack morton auditorium.
So it's really nice to be home again and I'm
really excited because we've got a great group
of people here to have this conversation with.
Um Gloria Borger is CNN's chief political
analyst. She plays an instrumental role in
our daily coverage on all kinds of political
and breaking news stories. Gloria. Um She
also covers midterm presidential elections,
congressional investigations. Lots of donald
trump you name it Gloria does it. We also
have David chalian. He is the vice president
of our political coverage and our political
director. Mhm David oversees all of our daily
political coverage, the polling, our decision
desk operations and obviously if you flip
on CNN you are very likely to catch him on
air in front of our magic wall of some sort
explaining whatever is going on on any given
day. He's always my first call when I, you
know, need help with something or have a set
of questions. He is, he is the go to Jasmine
Wright is a White House reporter with CNN
Jasmine now covers the White House. She was
a political embed for us in the 2020 presidential
election. She followed then Senator Kamala
Harris during the Democratic primary campaign.
And then she was an embed when Harris was
on the vice presidential ticket with joe biden,
so welcome to everyone. We are like selling
these guys were all thrilled, thrilled to
be here. And I think sam did a really nice
job of setting the stage for us because I
know David before um you know, we as we were
getting ready to do all of this, we were sort
of talking about, okay, how should we approach
this midterm election? Because it feels so
different than midterm elections in the past,
mostly because it doesn't seem to be about
a single thing like, like a one single topic.
And often they are, they're a referendum on
the party in power or there's, you know, one
overriding issue. I think we all went into
this thinking that that that would be the
economy and that's just not how it's turning
out to be breaking down as it is, right. And
then so there the election can be, the election
can be about a single thing for some voters.
But what is what cases getting out that I
think is so fascinating at this particular
moment in time, seven weeks out is that that
single thing can be different depending on
who you are. And obviously there's always,
when we ask folks sort of, what issue is driving
you, what's the most important issue in this
election to you? You get a range of answers,
but midterms usually do huddle around like
one sort of topic. And what we're seeing is
that there is this issue driven campaign about
the inflation, the economy, immigration and
crime that is driving the republican side
of the equation in american politics. And
on the other side we are seeing abortion rights
or the very foundations of our democracy and
trying to protect that uh those are issues
that are driving Democratic campaigns. And
so to me, the big that we have facing us as
we cover this over the next many weeks, is
which one of those campaigns, as we get closer
to Election Day and voters are making their
decisions proves to be the dominant one and
the most persuasive one, especially for those
folks in the middle. You know, what's so interesting
to me is that usually, as you were saying,
it's a referendum on the incumbent. And what
the democrats are saying is no, no, no, no,
no. It's not a referendum on the incumbent.
It's a referendum on republicans. It's a referendum
on extremism. And what the democrats are trying
to do is play in the culture wars. This is,
you know, republicans have always been quite
adept and done it very well playing on the
culture wars. And you see that in this election,
um, with immigration for example. But the
democrats now are saying, wait a minute. Uh,
we have abortion here, which is working in
our favor also, for example, healthcare, healthcare
is their issue and they can play on that.
And so they now believe they have some equity
there and they're trying to push that, even
though everybody knows as James Carville once
said, it's the economy stupid. And so it's
it's, you know, candidates have to, Democratic
candidates have to kind of try and balance
this. How much love do you give joe biden,
um, versus how independent are you? And what
issues do you emphasize in what part of the
country? So jasmine? Let me bring you in here
because when you cover the White House every
day, you're always talking to biden's team
to Harris's team. I mean, how do they view
it? Especially this question of the president
himself? Because it is a tough question for
a lot of Democratic candidates do you want
to appear with President biden considering
his approval rating? It's it's ticked up lately,
but it's not great. Yeah. Well, I think if
you look at the President's most recent travels,
he was just in pennsylvania and then you saw
him with Federman and that was a question
going into that event. Whether or not he would
appear um whether or not some of these candidates
who are in some of these trickier races would
flock to biden. Of course, you heard tim Ryan
running for Ohio Senate saying that, you know,
it's time for new leadership, but across the
board we're not seeing total um a rebuke of
bile. And and and I think you can look at
that because of some of the policies that
you have seen the White House get passed in
the last few weeks. When you talk about the
inflation reduction act, Of course, a few
months ago, when you talk about the bipartisan
infrastructure, when you talk about their
work on abortion rights, trying to really
send the message that they feel that the Supreme
Court took too many steps went too far when
it took away what they see as a constitutional
right. So I think that you're seeing more
for democrats at least warm up to the idea
that maybe we should tell all of the things
that President biden has done for the country,
all the things that he's gotten past. But
I think if you look at the President specifically
and how he is approaching this election, it's
exactly what you talked about, Gloria that
extremism, right? He's making it a referendum
not on himself so much of what he's done in
office, but on president trump former president
trump, even though he is not on the ballot,
you see him taking those really grand um condemnations
of former President trump in front of in in
speeches that they say this is not gonna be
political, right. And in ways saying that
this is the very fabric of democracy unraveling,
that his uh followers are motivated by semi
fascism. So you're seeing the President really
take it head on trying to shift some of the
focus from maybe the inflation inflation is
a little too high still, right? Maybe we didn't
do X, Y. Z. And shift it on. But if you continue
to elect folks who support president trump
this is the outcome that you're gonna get.
So let's let's kind of dig into the issues
here, because, I mean, broadly, broadly speaking,
this is really an argument between republicans
who want this election to be about high inflation,
immigration crime, border security, and who
want the election to be about what you're
talking about. They want it to be about preserving
democracy. They want it to be about abortion
rights, among other things. So let's start
with the Republican side, David. And let's
let's start with immigration, because it's
been such a flashpoint lately with what Rhonda
Santis has done sending immigrants to states
here in the Northeast. What do you view as
the motivating forces behind what he's done
and how do you think it's going to impact
the campaign? Well, listen, I think when you
think about immigration, I think you have
to think about it in two different ways. There
is clearly a huge immigration problem in the
country and on the southern border. I mean,
the statistics from customs and border protection
just this week indicated that there have been
more than two million encounters at the border.
That's a record setting number. So, there's
clearly a problem that Washington has, I don't
wanna say largely ignored, failed to be able
to find consensus to actually come up with
solutions. Right. So for decades. So, I mean,
since Ronald Reagan was president basically,
was the last time we saw George Bush tried
when I was a student here. Exactly, yeah.
And we saw it in the Obama years. It was,
it was tried and failed. So there, that's
only been a growing problem that Washington
has not successfully addressed yet. That is
true, right? That that exists. The other pocket
of immigration, if you look at is the pure
political play, which is what I I think you
see Rhonda Santis doing here, understanding
that it is an issue that motivates the Republican
base. Much more so than it does the democratic
base, uh, and it is an issue that can drive
up that enthusiasm inside that base. And so
doing something that is, you know, basically
a political stunt, like what he's doing of
uh, flying folks to Martha's vineyard to make
a point, there's no way around that, but that
that is pure politics and for political consumption
and for political programming, especially
on the right. And then I would just note the
third piece of this is of course when you're
doing that, there's a human component to what's
going on. That is a story that gets covered
as well and rightfully so about what's actually
happening when you decide to make a political
play with human, real human beings who are
having to be a part of it. But I think that
human being component is something that the
White House is trying to use to their advantage
when you talk to officials in the building,
they say that they feel that republicans miscalculated
and um, went too far in a lot of different
ways and therefore they're going to be aggressive
in the way that they address it. So from the
podium, you saw White House Press Secretary,
jean Pierre repeatedly called a political
stunt, repeatedly make it, um, use really
fierce language, some language that we don't
necessarily here forever every day from that
podium, when she's talking about the ways
that they feel that republicans de Santis
Abbott have gone too far have used these people
in ways that they shouldn't be used really
as a political stunt. Um and so I think that
the White House for that issue, immigration
is not something that they really want to
talk about. It is a good week for them if
they're not taking multiple questions on it.
And so I think you're seeing them really play
in the margins in terms of when it comes to
that cultural midterm elections are about
motivation there, about motivating your base
to come out. And de Santis uh did a pretty
good job of motivating republicans. I was
talking to a republican today in new Hampshire
who said this is great, you know, this, this
is great for us because it motivates people
to say, wait a minute, there's a problem at
the border. Why aren't you guys in the media
talking about the problem at the border? And
he did that? But but joe biden is saying they're
inhumane, Look at how inhumane the republicans
are, and what I think the republicans saw
was that on abortion, the democrats were motivating
their base and immigration is something that
motivates republicans crime. We're gonna be
hearing an awful lot more about crime and
a lot of different parts of the country, because
that also motivates the republican base. It's
all about. I mean, it's a cliche, but midterm
elections especially are about turnout. And
so what you're seeing is people trying both
parties trying to figure out a way to get
their people to the polls, I think for, you
know, for for all of you who are, you know,
starting to really learn about, you know,
kind of how these systems work and and observe
elections, you know, in your adult lives and
participate in them sometimes for the first
time. I mean, one of the big differences,
I think for us as we all cover midterm election
versus presidential elections, independent
voters are always a very important part of
that calculus. They do play a role in midterm
elections, but you can see from the way politicians
act that they are typically less important
in midterm elections. That base turnout is
what's the most important. It helps explain
like why joe biden gave the speech that he
gave, which frankly was polarizing potentially
for independent voters, Republican leaning
people who would be willing to vote for him,
but is very energizing for democrats. And
part of the reason why Democratic candidates
may be more willing to have him on the trail
is because most of his approval rating increases
actually among democrats. It's democrats who
are starting to say, oh, I was disappointed
with the president, but now I like him. And
that bodes well for trying to get people out
to the polls, which is really the battle in
the midterm elections. And it's like that's
why you hear us kind of spending so much time
um focused on it and David, do you think to
the extent that, you know, what we've seen
from de Santis and others. And and you could
wrap crime into this? I mean, I was looking
at, you know, the ads against Fetterman, for
example, in pennsylvania, who many of our
students are very online are probably the
most familiar with him over many of the other
senate candidates out there. I mean, Oz is
trying to really make some hay on his previous
positions on, you know, pardoning criminals
and other things. How much success do you
think republicans are having? Well, um, there
is no doubt that uh, there is some traction
on that issue when you, you know, when you
look at polling as much as you can believe
in polling these days, but like when you look
at polling, uh, that is an issue when crime
is front and center like that, that tends
to favor republicans when voters are asked
which party do you trust more to deal with
this issue? Um, Immigration, border security.
That has a crime component to it in some of
the messaging, but also just like straight
up like street crime. That or an increase
in violent crime in uh, in certain communities
is also a key component of the republican
messaging. In fact, I think in the last month,
crime has become the number one messaging
issue for republicans with advertising dollars.
So if you just look at where the campaigns,
the candidates, the parties are putting their
money, like what message they are funding
the most in the last month. For republicans,
it actually has been crime and for democrats
far away, it's abortion rights, which is also
just shows you the power of that Supreme Court
decision flipping on its head. I mean democrats,
we would cover for years and years races,
democrats never wanted to talk about abortion.
In fact, it was an issue that riled up, you
know, fight for overturning roe was an issue
that riled up and got uh right wing conservatives
uh enthused and engaged and you know, now
it's sort of like the dog that caught the
car after a 50 year quest. The court overturns
that and now It's the Democrats who are able
to utilize that issue as a motivating factor.
So I do think crime is something we have seen
works. I think what we saw in 2020K. C. If
you recall Republicans made greater inroads
in the house, they didn't win the majority
obviously, than many of them expected. You
know, never mind observers, just the Republican
candy. So running on this defund the police
attack that like, you know, labeling democrats
as the party for defund the police. That's
why you see President biden at a state of
the union address telling the country I want
to fund the police because he understood how
politically damaging that brand of defund
the police was for democrats and republicans
saw that they they believe they won greater
numbers in the House two years ago on that
alone. And I believe by the way, the D triple
C chairman, the Sean Patrick maloney who is
charged with winning and keeping the House
majority for democrats. I believe in his post-2020
analysis. He also cited that as a huge problem
for Democrats in 2020. So that's where I don't
think it takes. Like you can see in the numbers
where that messaging has worked for right
now. And I think it can also explain for those
of you that are paying attention to what Congress
is doing right now, Democrats are trying to
pass a law enforcement funding bill as we
speak because many of these Democrats were
trying to hold onto their vulnerable seats.
Really want them to do that. So let's switch,
let's sort of expand out here because I do
want to get into an in depth conversation
about abortion because I know it's something
that really that everyone is very, very interested
in. But but let's also talk about the economy
because this is really sort of fought over
territory, right? This is something republicans,
Gloria thought, you know, they were gonna
be able to run on the whole entire summer
gas prices did drop the White House, you know,
pretty big gift. But at the same time, we
just saw the Federal Reserve today raise interest
rates by, you know, three quarters of a percent
of a point. They clearly think inflation is
still a problem. How does this potentially
continue through the campaign? What what impact
do you see it having? I think the economy
is so important when you look at the polls,
people still say the economy is number one,
you know, there's no you're not going to dethrone
the economy. I was talking to somebody today
who said people's heating bills are gonna
go up even if their gas bills may be going
down. They see what's going on in the supermarket.
You know, this is where we live, this is important
to people. You go shopping and you see that,
you know that everything is everything is
going up. So I think it's a problem, particularly
when the White house, as much as they try
to message on this, the president will say,
well the rate of inflation going up is so
small. It's kind of plateaus and isn't that
good news for six months? Exactly, and that
people hear that and they go, you don't understand
me. And the one thing about joe biden is he
always tells his staff, you have to be able
to explain this policy to your grandmother
and I want you to be able to do that. Well,
they're not really succeeding at doing that
because people feel it. So it is still the
number one issue. Think of it as kind of the
wallpaper, I think that is that is behind
everything. And so they're trying to change
the subject and that abortion as you guys
were talking about is so important. Women
voters are registering in droves, You saw
what happened uh in Kansas. Um so I think
that um that is so important. So the social
issues and the cultural issues are really
important are going to drive people out there.
But in the end whether they say, you know
the famous Ronald Reagan line, do I feel better
today that I did four years ago except now
it's two years ago and people may forget that
there was a pandemic and therefore of course
the economy tanked and we're coming back and
etcetera etcetera, you can make that argument.
But when you talk to people at home, how do
you feel? They're gonna say, I don't feel
better than I felt two years ago and that's
hurting joe biden and I don't think there's
any way to get around it. Yeah, I mean there's
no if you think about the way that this White
House can impact the economy, they basically
done what they can do right? They have released
oil through the Strategic Reserve, they have
passed the inflation reduction act, which
you know, will take time. But they say that
that is going to bring down some of these
high numbers that we see right? Really, that
policy comes from the Federal Reserve and
the White House and joe biden says that those
are two separate entities and so they have
to let them work. So what they can do is message
that we understand, we understand that you
are paying more when you go to the grocery
store. But look at your gas prices. We understand
that it takes more money and time to get from
A to B. But think about student loans, right?
They can do things within the margin to make
people feel somewhat better about the economy.
But there's not a lot policy wise that they
can do, especially when you're talking about
how much time they have left between the midterms.
What is it? 49 50 days? So it's like, other
than maybe some permitting action on the hill
or, or the, the house on policing and policing
bill from the house. There's not so much that
they can do, which means that they turn to
messaging and they're turning to how can we
make our base feel excited? And that excitement
comes from student loans, right? That excitement.
How do we bring young people out for giving
$10,000 in student loans, doing something
that Biden said that he would do two years
ago. How do we turn people out, making sure
that they understand that we know that they
want a choice between their body autonomy.
So those are the kinds of things that we were
talking about shifting the messaging that
we see from the White house because President
biden knows as a man who is says he's a blue
collar president, he knows what it's like
to have, uh, your paycheck look shorter, right?
He knows what it's like to see those credit
card bills, at least his family does. He knows
what it's like. His credit card bills expand.
So I think that it's now the game of shifting
that messaging and seeing how we can pull
people from their homes to that ballot box
to that ballot. I mean, the reality is this
is a shift in messaging on the economy. It's
a very tough political message to fight republicans
and say, no things are not that bad while
simultaneously trying to empathize with people
who are having a really hard time. So the
answer bottom line is change the subject.
Um, so speaking of subjects, um, let's let's
switch gears a little bit because, you know,
abortion has been such an animated conversation
and David, when this first, when the decision
first came down, I certainly heard from a
lot of Republican sources who basically tried
to dismiss it. They're like, this is not gonna
help democrats very much. This is not gonna
be a big deal. Um, and as I think you used
the phrase, the dog who caught the car, I
had, you know, one republican member of Congress
who says he used to warn his colleagues like
you're shooting blanks right now when you're
talking about blank bullets, when you're talking
about, um, when you're talking about making
changes to abortion laws, but now you're firing
with live rounds now that the, it's actually
switched. Um and that what happens is very
politically dangerous. Yeah. So I'll go back
a few months before the decision, you know,
as far back as february, I was talking to
some uh Democratic officials, White House
officials, campaign strategists, uh all of
whom were already anticipating this decision
right, was going to go this way even before
the leaked opinion came out and already sort
of circling it as we are facing an election
that has so many headwinds, the party in power.
What happens in the first in the President's
first term, midterms historically with the
economy and the inflation, everything that
was going on, They knew they had a lot of
headwinds and to a person, they were like,
but when the Supreme Court overturns roe v
wade, we're gonna be in a different universe.
A lot of Democratic strategists really believed
it had the potential to change the calculus.
Um and yes, I talk to republicans to who downplayed
it. But honest republicans like, like, their
most honest, I realized that it was gonna
be uh something they were going to contend
with. The glorious point that we should just
be careful here as we're gonna do this deep
dive into abortion rights. Now, it is not
clear that it is going to be sufficient to
withstand all the things Gloria said about
the economy and historically what happens,
we don't know that what we know is at this
moment in time, there is no doubt that the
court decision and the political fallout from
it has shifted the political landscape. I
think every republican and democrat on a ballot
would concede that in this moment it shifted
from what it was, which looked like it was
going to be a massive red wave wipe out of
a year. Now add gas prices coming down, donald
trump becoming more front and center. There
are other factors, well, but nothing like
the dobbs decision that ignited the democratic
base into a moment of action in this season,
It just shifted the terrain beneath all these
politicians. And again, I just think we should
be careful as we think through this because
whether or not that is actually sufficient
to overcome all these other factors. I don't
think we know that yet. And I I just would
be wary about what we do know is that women
are registering to vote. And we saw that in
Kansas before there was the question of a
referendum on whether abortion should be banned
in the, in the state of Kansas, there were
uh, there were statistics and I don't know
how accurate they were. You know, the show
that 70% of the new registrants and in Kansas
were democratic women. I don't, I can't verify
that, to be honest. Um, and then there there
are data that show that in some places women,
suburban women are registering to vote and
democrats are kind of hanging their hat on
that saying, well maybe that will change the
balance. Um we don't know, I don't think we
know, I just don't think we know whether it's
going to be enough and if, you know, you talk
to democratic pollsters, um they will, they're
very excited, but they're also nervous about
it because they don't know, they don't know
either and they don't want to get over excited
about it because of these headwinds that that
we've all been talking about Casey when you
talk about live rounds like now, like after
and again, I don't know how to convey. I guess
I've been covering politics a long time now
and there's been one constant through a couple
decades of covering politics, which has been
the energy of the pro life movement. Okay,
that every political rally I've ever covered
democrat or Republican and therefore uh, the
pro life folks were either protesting that
person or supporting that person, but they
were the guaranteed um, I don't wanna say
interest group, but sort of issue oriented
voters showing up like every where every like
it was, it was the constant other issues would
come and go. Other activists would show up
at these events. But, and I'm sure you saw
this when you were on the campaign trail as
well, guaranteed were the were pro life voters
who you want to see it walking around campus
people with posters. I mean it's it's the
most common common thing. And so To have a
50-year quest and motivation and to reach
the promised land, obviously a hugely successful
moment for that movement. But as republican
politicians always said, well, it's now going
to go back to the states. So the moment it
happens, it creates all these questions for
candidates back in the states about what their
state laws are going to be dealing with this
issue. And that has created uh sort of political
quicksand. And I think just to put a fine
point on that, you you have to think about
how the issue of abortion is gonna play in
different states, right? Take new Hampshire
and Georgia, two very important senate races.
And obviously Maggie Hassan is having some
trouble time. Um, she's neck and neck with
her opponent, but some democrats feel like
abortion is going to be the thing. If she
holds on that seat, that is what got her over
the line. That is what got suburban women
out. But then you take a look at Georgia and
you take a look at that vote in 2020 obviously
they flip for joe biden. It came down to black
voters, it came down to asian voters, but
neither of those groups are monolithic and
specifically when you talk about black voters,
there is a certain sect of a black voter that
actually goes to the polls, that is not pro
choice. You can't just automatically assume
that black voters are going to be in favor
of abortion. So the issue of abortion plays
so differently when it comes to different
sectors of the country because of those constituents.
So it's not necessarily going to be something
that um, you know of obviously, we don't know
how it's going to turn out, but I think that
if you're reverend, Warnock, who is very astute
in the church, he's not going to necessarily
be putting all of his eggs in the abortion
basket to say it's one of the reasons Stacey
Abrams is so interesting because she has not
always been as, you know, pro abortion rights
as she is being in this particular campaign,
as she she works on turnout. Can I say, one
add one other thing about another issue that
interests me over the years. I mean, you talk
about how important abortion has been for
the Republican Party, the pro life movement
has been so constant gun control, which was
striving to get to that moment where you could
depend on your voters to come out as demo
democratic voters to say, look, we're pro
gun control. Some in the Democratic Party
were very hopeful that you validate, for example,
would be a motivating moment for Democratic
voters to come out and say, okay, finally,
and joe biden has done something on gun control.
However small it was exactly still passed
a bipartisan bill. And for some reason, and
it's so interesting for some reason, the issue
of guns, um, which is personal to everyone,
not as personal as a woman's rights. Um it's
to choose, etcetera, but that never reached
the level of interest and motivation and that
um that abortion has or the constancy that
abortion has even after Newtown, even after
you've all done now, what we see in pulling
around guns is interest and motivation surge
around one of those horrific events that like
dominate our consciousness. And, you know,
there's a huge surge of interest in motivation.
And when that begins to fade, and this is
what activists say all the time, and they're
so concerned about as they're trying to argue
for this when that fades from the headlines.
So too does the polling follow that, and it
just becomes an issue with less salience for
voters well, and I think just no, no, you're
fine to bring it to bring it back to, you
know, abortion. I think this is gonna be a
big question for democrat activists who care
about this issue is how are they going to
continue the momentum around this? Because,
you know, it is very hard to sustain interest
focus to raise money around a particular,
you know, pick your political issue and keep
the spotlight trained on it. I mean, gun control
is a very, very good example of this and the
pro life movement really did a really striking
job of doing it on the issue that they really
cared the most about. And I think it's going
to be in interesting to see if this is something
that, you know, a has an impact in the election
that we're talking about in the way that David
is talking about. But be whether they can
continue that as they continue to fight for
what they want politically. And you know,
David, I was struck by you were talking about
talking to people in february one of the things
that I think is most salient for people about
this abortion debate right now is that the
Supreme Court took quite literally the most
extreme available route to this right? So
john roberts who has developed something of
a reputation as kind of the center center
weight of the court, you know, tried, we've
learned from these leaks to find some sort
of maybe not middle ground if you're an abortion
rights supporter, but something that put some
protected some element of that right to 15
weeks of pregnancy with potentially with exceptions.
And perhaps the current, what did happen was
john roberts ultimate goal. But what he really
was trying to do was sort of like elongate
the path there and try to bring the country
along. So, I mean, so that but I think what
happened was, you know, now you have states
where, you know, their policies are just way
far off where americans are in terms of what
they think abortion policy should be. They
are, you know, either complete bands very
draconian at six weeks. They don't include
exceptions for rape and incest in the life
of the mother. I'm just curious, David, I
my sense is that's part of what is so animating
and why it is that this is such a strong issue
in the midterms. No, no doubt about it, no
doubt about it. Had the Supreme Court come
to again, maybe not a middle ground, but like,
had, first of all, had they just dealt with
the Mississippi factor and not dealt with
row at all, right? That probably would not
have been as motivating of a moment because
it would not have been that the culmination
of that 50 year battle, right? Um but as you're
saying, if there were some, we we can see
in the polling some restrictions on abortion
are politically popular. Um and but there's
there's a continuum and the court in Dobbs
just went all the way to one end of the continuum
and ignited this potential opportunity for
democrats. Clearly, some backlash out in the
country around this. I just want you brought
up Kansas glory, and I just wanna mention
one other thing because as Casey was saying,
it's unclear, you know, can you keep this
going as an issue all the way through this
election and beyond. But what Kansas that
Gloria cited the stats about the registration
in Kansas their abortion was literally on
the ballot, right? It was not just an issue
being brought up by candidates and so look
for where abortion rights are going to be
an actual issue on the ballot, like in a referendum
where voters are voting. Um one of the key
battleground states in american politics is
going to have that on the ballot in michigan
and that uh we may see a totally different
kind of electorate in turn out the way we
saw in Kansas in michigan this year, because
this issue is literally on its own on the
ballot, not just rhetorical, it's not being
carried by, you know, a candidate that has
a whole slate of other issues or potential
problems or, you know, is affecting people
because they have a d or an r by their name.
It's just asking people yes or no on this
particular issue. It's a much different scenario
well, and it's been my experience when you
try and take something away from people, they
don't like it and this is taking something
away from women That has been the law for
50 years like this. This isn't just saying,
Okay, you know, we're changing your tax law,
maybe you can deduct this this year, but you
couldn't deduct it before. This is something
that's been there for 50 years and it's very,
very and and this is the reason I believe
that Republicans had such difficulty figuring
out a way to take away obamacare Because people
had obamacare and and they really didn't,
it was imperfect and everything else, but
they couldn't figure out a way to take it
away, that wouldn't be unpopular. So, you
know, it's kind of politics. 101 people like
something women sort of came to accept it
as part of their lives utilize it, you know,
like and so I think that that's the message
that the White House is trying to drive home.
You see the Vice president, Kamala Harris
basically at every opportunity. She's going
three times a week to different states to
talk to their legislators to try to say, okay,
how do we form a national message on abortion
that can carry us from september now to november?
And it's that idea of that you don't have
to this is something that she says and I listened
to it a lot, so I can almost recite it by
word. She says that you don't have to be pro
choice, right? That's her message. You don't
have to be pro choice, but you do have to
kind of believe that women should be allowed
to choose whatever they want to do. You don't
have to be pro abortion. And so I think that
that is going to be that kind of national
message that democrats who know that some
of the people coming to the ballot may not
be gung ho about abortion, may, they may have
religious um uh feelings about it. They may
just not want that to happen. But they are
still understanding that women should be able
to do with what they want with their body.
And so I think that when you what the White
House is trying to do when you talk to aides
inside the White House, they're trying to
break it down to the most simple language
that it is not necessarily about this very
political thing. It's about a woman having
the freedom to do what she wants with what
she will. And I think that that the basic
message is how democrats feel like they can
reach beyond just those very energized woman
voters. They can get to male voters, they
can get to folks who traditionally are very,
very religious, who necessarily wouldn't want
to vote in favor of abortion by the way, you
all don't know this perhaps, but Jasmine is
the national expert on all things Kamala Harris
covering Kamala Harris nonstop for CNN for
four years now. So If any of you ever end
up or working on a political campaign and
you go to these rallies, I mean, I can still
recite like Mitt Romney's from 2012 by heart,
so I'm sure is going to be like that for your
whole life. So before we turn to take some
of our we've got a ton of questions from our
audience. So thank you guys so much for for
all the interest, but we do need to talk about
the elephant in the room and uh that is donald
trump um because obviously, you know, we've
talked a lot about is this a referendum on
the president, Is this, what is this election?
The White house and democrats clearly would
love for this to be a choice between joe biden
and Donald trump again. Because if you remember
uh joe biden did in fact win, Donald trump
did lose to joe biden, David, what what role
do you think the president sort of very public
travails are having on the midterms here in
the final stretch? Um you know, the Donald
trump factor uh and it is one uh in american
politics and in this election season, it's
always a bit, you know, it's a two sided coin.
Donald trump has a proven ability at least
when he is on the ballot. We will see what
his proven ability is uh not being on the
ballot, but he has a proven ability to drive
up turnout. Um among his core base of support.
Two record setting numbers by the way. You
know, like we saw in 2020 when he lost that
election to Joe Biden, he had increased his
vote chair and and turned out voters uh that
had not voted before that and he has this
um I would call it perhaps the strongest connection
to a base of voters that I've ever seen a
politician have in my entire time covering
politics. And so there's that side where him
being out there has the potential to do that.
The flip side of the coin is of course it
also has the potential to repel the independent
and swing voters in these battleground districts
and battleground states that are critical
to Republican successes in winning the majorities
in the House and the Senate, uh, that, you
know, revolted away from trump in 2020 and
delivered the White House to joe biden, that
in 2018 delivered the Democratic majorities,
uh, that you see today, uh, in, in the House.
So I do think that he he does have both of
that. There is, there is some evidence to
suggest that there has been some diminishment
of support even among republicans with everything
that Donald trump is facing day in and day
out though. I think that there's a lot of
um, overriding and over analyzing about that
diminishment of support because I think it
is, uh, there's not a lot of evidence to suggest
that it's anything but rather small at the
moment. He is the clear, um energy inside
the Republican Party. He is the clear sort
of um, north star for the Republican primary
electorates that we saw throughout this primary
season in most places. So I, um, you know,
I think that republicans who are trying to
win the majorities are not eager like mitch
McConnell to like have Donald trump front
and center. They don't, they think it gets
them off the message of the economy inflation,
immigration, crime, immigration, even if their
message is that Donald trump will talk about,
but Donald trump talks about Donald trump
and he talks about his grievances and the
republican establishment trying to win these
majorities, knows that so they don't see him
as particularly helpful if he is front and
say and clearly the democrats do see him as
particularly helpful to their efforts if he
is front and center, that's why joe biden
gave that speech in philadelphia. So I do
think he will be a factor. I don't I don't
know that That calculus that I just described
Casey is somehow going to prevent the Republicans
from being able to win majorities. If you
know, on something like the economy, he'll
be a factor. I don't think he'll be the defining
factor, right? I think what's interesting
to me about by, I mean about Trump is that
for the longest time, all he talked about
was how he won, you know, the 2020 election
and there were a lot of Republicans, he's
still talking about it. Um and there are a
lot of republicans who are getting sick of
that and saying we have to look to the future.
We can't look to the path now, he's got something
else about himself to talk about which is
the search at mar a Lago and in that he has
made himself the victim, which he does very
well and the FBI is the bad guy and you know,
big government is the bad guy. And you saw
what happened after that search, he rallied
the troops tremendously. He raised an awful
lot of money off of it And he's still going
to be talking about it because of course now
these legal cases and we have the January
six hearing coming back next week and wrapping
up, but these legal cases are going to continue
and continue. So he has another way to present
himself as a victim, which is not only the
fact that he won the election, as he says
in 2020, but now they're out to get him. And
this is something that very much appeals to
his base and republicans have twisted themselves
in knots over what really happened at mar
a Lago should he have had those documents.
Um and it's a problem for them. And it may
be keeping Donald trump from announcing for
the presidency as quickly as we thought he
was gonna do, because he can use the money
from his pack to pay his legal fees. Um but
it's another, it's another twist in the in
the Donald trump story and how that's going
to affect everything. So this is a great segue
into a couple of great questions we got that
are on this, this topic. I was talking to
a Republican candidate who recently who actually
had worked for Donald trump but ended up being
the sort of more mainstream of the candidates
in this particular race. And this person pointed
out to me that these were the kinds of things
he was meeting voters on the trail um day
in and day out, who were absolutely convinced
of the things that Donald trump was saying
about the election in particular, um that
it was stolen from Donald trump. And, you
know, this is somebody who has been around
politics a long time, who really understood,
you know, kind of like how these things are
and um was just flabbergasted by the way that
this information had kind of come out into
the electorate and was just absolutely impossible
to dislodge. And so one of the questions that
we have here, um, and David, I'll start with
you here. Um, what do you make of candidates
who are changing their stances on stop the
steal? Because one of the last most recent
race we had was new Hampshire right? Where
Don baldwin, who became the Republican nominee,
came out the next day and immediately changed
his position on this, but needed to message
to those voters apparently in the primary
to win over someone who refused or at least
wouldn't go as far as he did to say that the
election was stolen. Yeah, I mean, bulldog
is the most uh extreme example yet, uh, that
exists. And I think one reason why is that
he didn't have donald trump's endorsement.
So while he definitely courted the trump base
and leaned into his support of the election
denialism. Uh, and no doubt wanted Donald
trump's endorsement that that is clear trump
didn't play in that race. And what that allowed.
So that allowed Baldock to do this complete
now it may not work for him. I'm not suggesting
it, but to do this just complete 1 80 be like,
no, now I'm in a general election and I'm
not gonna run on that because you can do it
without the fear that he was going to be bedeviled
by two weeks of headlines of donald trump.
Now pulling his endorsed because he no longer
supports his lie about the election. As we
saw play out in some other races, like in
the Alabama senate races here, what have you?
So that actually freed him up to do that again.
I'm not suggesting that the general election
voters in new Hampshire are gonna buy that
flip. I'm just saying that no, it was a very
tough change. So we had another question along
these lines. Um, someone asks how will these
republicans influence turnout, but I'm particularly
interested in the second half of the question
was how do you think that these candidates
will react? And I'm thinking of Kari Lake
in Arizona, how will they react if they lose?
Well, I think you've seen it already. I think
that they there is a good chance, at least
we don't know what anyone's gonna do, but
I think that there's a good chance that they
will follow the playbook that the former president
laid out himself saying that something was
wrong, This was, you know, falsely claiming
that there were errors that there was michigan's
about, you know, that there was joe biden
may put it malarkey happening. And um I think
that there has been enough That was done after
the 2020 election, that there is a pathway.
And I think also another part of this midterm
is gonna be about who are the state officials
that are being put into these states that
have to eventually certify the results on
the state level, not just in the Congress.
And so I think that there is kind of a whole
machine afoot about how these elections are
gonna go if if somebody loses. Well they're
not gonna be decided overnight, people are
gonna challenge elections right left, you
have election deniers running for office huge
numbers and um so I think this sort of old
days of when you have a campaign and it was
done the next day, you knew who the what the
result was when there was a tight race in
pennsylvania donald trump told Oz dr Oz just
declare you one now, he ended up winning.
And but remember what trump said to him, just
say you won. Remember what happened after
this election? Donald trump came out at what
two or three in the morning, you all remember
we were all up saying I won, I won. So I think
we're gonna actually see a lot of that and
I think a lot of the election machinery is
changing as you were saying. Um, and that
would support that. So, uh, everyone has to
be very careful. Everyone has to understand
every vote counts. Everyone has to preserve
democracy and hopefully There will be so many
eyes on every election that um, we won't have
massive problems, but you can't predict that
that won't happen. Yeah, I mean, and I think,
you know, one of the lessons of 2020 is that
there were a lot of unsung heroes, Republicans
in some of these critical states and thinking
of rusty bowers in Arizona Brad Raffensperger
in Georgia. I mean, who would have thought
that these people would become. household
names for many of us, but they are really
the only thing that stood in between, uh,
the actual result of the election being protected
and a very concerted effort from Donald trump.
And we have heard the calls he made to brad
raffensperger to attempt to change his mind.
And there are a lot of people who might have
folded under pressure like that. So we've
got a couple of critical races like that on
the ballot coming up to keep an eye on. Um,
let's switch gears because we haven't really
dug into this jasmine, you mentioned, um,
student loan forgiveness, which we have a
couple questions about that, which I'm sure,
you know, many people in this room are, are
dealing with potentially having to confront
that over over the coming years? Um, we have
one that says, do you believe the issue of
student debt forgiveness will present itself
as a prevalent topic among youth voters and
how do you think people Democratic Congress
people will respond? I mean, I think it's
hard to tell, I think it's too early. Um,
I think that that's one of the reasons why
we have exit polls right to see who is voting.
For what reason I do think that it is something
that when I talk to, not just young people,
but specifically young people. When I talk
to my family members, they asked me number
one or number two, when is joe biden gonna
forgive student loans? Uh how much is he gonna
forgive? And so I think that this is something
that when you talk to officials before decision
came out, they knew that he had to come out
and say whether or not he was going to do
it. Um, and now that the decision is that
they feel that it is something that he lived
up to what he said he was gonna do. Um, he
never said more than 10,000, even though of
course like the CCP chuck schumer, you name
it, we're trying to make them go 50,000, of
course we have the 20,000 propel grants. So
I think that it is something that the White
house feels as though they have given to folks
who have massive debt and though it may, it
may not eclipse their debt, it will provide
some relief and that is the relief that joe
biden was comfortable with. And um I think
that they feel like that is just gonna be
another data point to show this is how the
President took care of you. There are lots
of moderate democrats who hated it and have
used it as a way to say, I don't agree with
Joe biden on everything Because it is unpopular
in certain places among people who say, look,
I paid my, I paid my loans back, why are you,
why are you giving somebody else you know,
money when I scrimped and saved and I paid
my loans back and the people who are gonna
get this $10,000 don't really need the money.
So it was very controversial and some Democrats
liked it and and some moderates running for
office are using it as a way to say, look,
I don't agree with Joe Biden and everything,
but the White House knew that they knew that
nobody would be fully happy with their decision.
One because it was $10,000. A lot of people
wanted more. The second part is because some
people did not think that he should do, it
shouldn't be the government's role to forgive
the student loans. It's not fair, it's not
equitable, but he made that choice and the
White House made that choice because they
felt like this was something that he could
easily follow through on and there were a
lot of advocates, including the vice president
that wanted him to go forward with it, but
he struggled with it. It took him a lot of
time and it's because joe biden was in a position
that he doesn't like to be in, which is that
he took a position that he knew was going
to be very politically popular with the base
of his party and he didn't want to have to
confront his own base of his party and this,
yet he understood that it really divided the
country pretty equally, that it was not necessarily
an overall winning political position to be
in, which job doesn't like that calculus he
doesn't like to just play as Gloria said,
he wants to explain stuff that everybody's
grandmother can understand and get behind.
Like he doesn't love being in a position of
like, I know it's going to make these friends
of mine happy and I don't want to invite a
problem here inside my family. But I also
know that it is going to be a divisive issue
broadly for the american people, which the
polling shows that it is. Yeah, I mean, and
I think, you know, one of the things that,
um, you know, I've learned over the years
of covering politics and you know, I come
from a group in the philadelphia suburbs.
Uh, we weren't wealthy, but we never wanted
for anything. Everybody that I knew went to
college and I'm sure many of you are in that
position. We may have some people who are
the first person in their family to go to
college in this room tonight. I'm, I'm not
sure. But either way, everybody sitting here
is in a very privileged position because the
reality is that most americans don't have
a college degree. Uh, and so when you try
to understand some of the dynamics underlying
a lot of these issues, you know, when you're
coming from one perspective, it seems obvious
to you, but it's not necessarily as obvious
to everyone. Um, so I think that's, you know,
just something to keep in mind as you're all
kind of progressing on on your journeys, whether
you end up working in politics and media or,
or anywhere else? Um, let's talk about the
inflation reduction act because we actually
got several questions about that doesn't actually
reduce inflation, when will inflation today
tomorrow. Um, This one's actually about climate
change because the bill actually does include
a bunch of measures related to that. But this,
our questioner who unfortunately is nameless
but asks with previous initiatives, we've
seen that they just haven't been enforced
or they haven't been enforced appropriately.
Do you think it's gonna be different this
time? Who knows? I mean, who knows joe biden
is going around the country saying, look,
we're doing this for electric cars were putting
in, You know, electric stations, we're doing
so we don't, we, you know, we don't know who's
going to control the congress next time. So
we don't know what is done, that could be
undone. But again, in this terms of undoing
things, there are lots of republicans who
believe in climate change. So I think that,
you know, there's a, you know, who knows?
You know, the answer to that is, who knows.
They ought to be bragging about it, just like
they ought to be bragging in the inflation
reduction act, which is just terribly named,
they ought to be bragging about bringing down
your prescription drug costs eventually by
in what, 2025 I think it is. Um, so they ought
to be talking about that stuff and they're
not, and they, one of the lessons of Gloria
is saying is that if they name a bill something
you should always be skeptical about whether
or not it actually right, they can't, and
when it, when it inflation is so high, it's
just like, this is not, not a good look, this
is both parties problem. It's not just an
inflation reduction. I probably. Um, so, David,
here's another question. Um, gas prices, If
they go up again, how bad is that for democrats?
Um, not good. I don't like, I don't, I don't
know any democrat that or I don't know any
republican who wants to see gas prices go
up either. But politically, you don't want
to be the party in charge of everything while
people are feeling pain at the pump. Now the
White House touted for 99 days in a row that
the gas prices went down and, uh, we'll see
if they do indeed go back up now in a significant
way. But here is the reality that's down from
some absurdly high place. I don't know how
many of you have cars here. You're all sort
of, uh, Public transportation dependent at
the moment or walking around. But uh, but
it from such a ridiculously high place in
June, uh, 99 days now down obviously is a
story you want to sell if you're in charge.
The reality is, people are still paying more
for gas than they were a year ago right now.
So, uh, that, uh, is never a good place that
you want to be if you're the party in charge
and you're about to go to the voters and ask
them to re up your contract and what do you
do do you say? Okay, there's a war in Ukraine
and the Russians have done this and this is
terrible. And this is why this, that's probably
what they'll say. That's what they said in
the past. It's hard though. It's hard because
a lot of people say, sorry, not my problem.
Like my gas prices are up and I can't afford
it. So it's, it's just not a good place to
be, no matter how hard you're trying to bring
them down. So we're nearing the end of our
our time here together tonight. But I wanted
to end on on this question because I remember
being in your shoes and wanting to know the
answer. Um what advice do you have for young
people looking to have a career in journalism
or politics and anything you would have done
differently? And jasmine, let's start with
you because you are at least at the beginning
of your political journalism career as an
embed. And you have made you have just done
incredible work in the time that you've been
there and what what what would you recommend
to our friends here? Yeah. Well, so I went
to University of Illinois um urbana, champaign
champaign Urbana. I'm from Chicago and I moved
to D. C. To start working. So I'd already
graduated college and I think that if I were
talking to myself out of out of college, I
would say go for everything. You can only
hear if you hear a no, that's not the worst
case scenario, right? Um when I was talking
to David about becoming a political in bed,
I don't think he knows this, but I barely
knew what a political embed was. I'm not kidding,
I did not know what it was, but he was so
convincing and I was nervous about being away
from home. I was nervous about the the work
that that would have to go into what everyone
was like. Yeah, it's a lot, it's a lot, but
I decided to do it and it was the greatest
decision of my life because you get to do
so much immersion into actually what politics
looks like. So I think that a lot of times
as young people, we feel like maybe that's
not right for me or I'm not ready for that
right now or I shouldn't do that right now.
I think that you should basically completely
ignore that part of your brain and do whatever
it is that you set out to do, find whatever
opportunities you can talk to people if you're
ever talking to somebody that works in politics,
get their phone number if you want to be a
reporter or you want to be in politics their
phone, people don't change their phone numbers,
they always have them, you can always call
them here. People don't change. It's too much
of a hassle. So I just think you have to go
for that opportunity, even if it's not exactly
there, even if you have to kind of wiggle
to get it because you're never going to be
disappointed if you do something that you
didn't think you could do and you do it well.
And the one thing, you know, the job Jasmine
had as a political embed, if journalism is
what you want and it's the school of media
and public affairs, that political embed job
is, there is no job like it in the industry,
it is every network has them. Um it is absolutely
something that you should try to do and the
person who decides who's gonna be the best
CNN is David chalian. So David, what would
you say to our friends here? Um, I, you know,
I always tell folks when I get this question,
I had such an unconventional path. And so
one of the things I would suggest to folks
is um you will find that a lot of people when
you go and talk to them about a potential
job, whether in politics or media, well, where
do you see yourself in five years or what
is your, you don't need to know the answer
to that. Like the, the journey is the thing
and like, you don't have to have it all mapped
out from here to there and and be okay with
that because each experience is gonna inform
you and and build who you are going forward.
The one thing I always suggest to young people
just starting out is, it's a different slice
of what Jasmine was saying, but say yes, say
yes to everything. So when you get an opportunity
and it may be, is not, you know, you think
you're above it or it's a little too small
bore for you. Um, but it is like a foot in
the door to what can grow into say yes to
that, because there's no, like I find in these
jobs in both the news and from talking to
sources in the political world who start out
their careers, they're like, there's no real
small job, It's such a um collaborative environment,
Everybody is sort of on a team and and really
trying to work towards the same goals and
being any part of that is a good place to
be. And so I would just urge, I know we spend
all this money on our education, we emerge
and we, you know, think that like, we should
be at a certain level, or just if you say
yes to stuff and you are um, coming with your
full self to that and saying yes, I'm gonna
throw myself into this, I'm gonna put my head
down, I'm going to do this job being asked
of me that is going to be rewarded time and
time again, David's absolutely right. And
one of the greatest things about being here
at G. W is that you are in the thick of it
and you have all year to do it, not just the
summer, which puts you at a huge advantage
when you're competing with kids from, you
know, ivy league schools that we won't name
Gloria. Well, I want to echo what David said
in a little bit of a different way, which
is don't look for the perfect job. They're
starting out and even now there is no perfect
job. So let me just say to you don't look
for the perfect job. Look for what's out there
and be excited about whatever it is that you
can get because if you're excited the people
you work with will be excited too and they
will notice your excitement. I mean I'm gonna
date myself now but I'm gonna tell you what
my first job was. Um I started out when I
was an intern at the Washington star which
is a newspaper. Remember those that no longer
exists in Washington D. C. I sat at a bank
with Maureen Dowd. Now a columnist at the
new york Times. That's how that's how we that's
how we became good friends is we used to take
dictation um from reporters in the field who
were dictating stories to us on deadline for
the afternoon newspaper. So they'd be talking
to me and I remember and I don't know how
to type by the way. So I'd be like making
these ridiculous, ridiculous mistakes but
I would be. And I when I first got that job
I thought and I was an intern, I thought this
is dumb. I know how to I want to write a story.
Well I ended up writing stories but I learned
how to write them by listening to great reporters
on deadline who were talking to me in my ear
about breaking news. And so while I first
thought God this is ridiculous. I'm not a
secretary, I'm a reporter. Well that led me
to understand how to write a story. and so
I said yes and then I said yes to every other
job that came along that maybe I thought well
I'm better than this. Well I wasn't better
than that and I learned and I and I wanted
to do everything because I wanted to learn
my business and I wanted to learn my craft
and so my thing is to play on what nancy Reagan
used to say, just say yes, okay, just say
yes to everything that comes along and it
won't be a bad decision. No, it's it's all
very good advice and you know, for my part
I would just say I I kind of have it in my
head is the three PS the first one is the
phone, pick up the phone. Yeah, everybody
now, you know, we're all inclined, I mean
and I'm guilty of it too. I send a text or
I send an email instead of picking up the
phone every single time I failed to pick up
the phone, I regret it. And whenever I do,
I learned more than I would have if I hadn't.
And for a lot of you who are gonna be going
out into the world, the people that are gonna
be hiring, you are still people who you know
had Blackberrys and Palm pilots and etcetera.
You know those connections that you make when
you pick up the phone are so important to
me to my second one, which is perseverance
when, when I was a student at G. W. Um I was
actually working for NBC News with a guy named
Mark Murray who is still there and who I worked
with, you know many years later he was helping
me get a job at National Journal magazine
and the editor there interviewed me went really
well and he called me at the end and he said
I've got two candidates, you know, I really
want to hire this guy who's an editor at the
Harvard Crimson this summer and you know,
I don't know what he's gonna say, but if he
says no, you know, I'm happy to have you as
a bummer. Right, I actually appreciate the
honest, but that was that's why I saw chip
on my shoulder about the ivy league um but
you know, so I said okay fine, you know whatever,
but you know, so I just, every friday this
was you know, probably april I needed to decide
by May and you know, I wasn't in a position
where I could take an unpaid internship, this
this job happened to pay so I needed to know
I needed to know if I was gonna do this or
if I was gonna go, you know, find a job waiting
tables or something. Um and every friday in
april I called back and every friday the editor
said to me, you know I'm so sorry I still
haven't heard from this guy from Harvard um
you know I'll be back in touch if if anything
changes. I said okay called again the next
friday same thing. And then finally at the
end of the month I was like look I gotta make
a decision here. I said to him like you know,
do you I really want this internship, I really
want this job, it's really important to me.
Um And he said you know what, I'm so sorry,
I haven't heard from Harvard guy hung up.
I said all right, I guess that ship has sailed
two minutes later he picks up the phone and
he calls me back, he's like, you know what?
This Harvard guy clearly doesn't want this
job as bad as you and that matters more to
me at the end, it's clear to me that you're
gonna do better at this, so it's yours. And
so that was how you know, I got my foot, my
first, you know written written bylines and
a printed publication was by doing that. Um
And so I would just recommend to you that
if you are rejected, don't let it get you
down. Um don't let it stop. You. Don't let
it, you know, get into your own head and make
you judge yourself because if you work hard
enough, you know the right thing will come
your way and that's my my third peak is just
people. Um And especially as you're you know,
kind of getting started here in Washington
D. C. This is a very, very small town and
if I had, you know, I I do remember I once,
I don't think anybody knew, but I was extraordinarily
hungover when I took, I just take the Metro
five in the morning from here to NBC's offices,
which were then up in Tenley Town. Um and
I was working for a guy who, you know, lo
and behold, you know, five years later, that's
where I finally got my break on the air where
I spent, you know, eight years of my career.
I worked with this guy every single day. He
has to, this day, one of my friends. Um and
it just sort of goes to show you mean David
and I have known each other. I mean, I don't
know how many years we've only now just started
to work at the same network Gloria as well.
The people that you get to know if you get
your foot in in this, I mean, this is an industry
town, so if you stay here and you work in
the industry, um politics, media, it's all
connected. It's all intertwined lobbying the
hill, everybody knows each other. And for
two reasons. One, you know, try not to show
up hungover to the internship, not a great
plan, but to, you know, these relationships
are what are going to get you your next job,
right? And so you saying yes to that boss,
you know, you're figuring out what my boss
want for me and saying yes and building that
relationship is gonna be, what will get you
your next thing. I mean, I've only ever gotten
one job in my entire life from responding
to a job posting. And it was my very first
internship at NBC News and ever since then
it's all about finding someone that, you know,
who works at the next place, who knows your
work and and that really, I mean, it becomes,
I think more true as you get older in life
because you know the beginning when you're
starting out, people are only gonna know you
by your resume, but don't let those things
lapse and and really focus on them as you're
getting. Did you ever learn who the editor
of the Crimson was that you were up against
for that job? No, I would really like to know.
Alright. I think that's gonna do it. We're
a little bit over time. Thank you guys so
much for being here tonight. We really appreciate
it.